[Music]
welcome back to the careful boys where
we're very careful boys
this is how careful we are we are so
careful that we are diversifying
everything yeah we're just trying to
bring the worlds together so if we vote
equally both sides doesn't that mean
we are equal yeah
yeah we have two presidents
this is a true democracy we should have
two presidents really why don't we have
four presidents why not a council like
in star wars we should have four
presidents that's why they call them
forefathers right dude that's the best
part of star wars when they go to the
council yeah dude and yoda's in the
yoda's in the middle you know what i
mean all the jedi i missed the center
with a bunch of naked 70 year olds with
togas on oh yeah what senate is that
dude oh like ancient greece oh yeah yeah
oh or or they wanted to [ __ ] the oracle
yes i know what you're talking about
that's deep but yes talking about the
matrix no the three hundred these are on
three hundred if you're talking about
[ __ ] young people
you gotta put on the right hat yeah wait
wait wait trump knew galen maxwell
put it back put a bunk they all know
if you hate minorities put on the right
hand and and epstein see how we forget
epstein like that see how that happens
that's true leave it hip-hop okay yeah
yeah
hip-hop
oh my god this is the first episode of
live at the trump tower jk news here we
go special edition special edition we
had to do this because steve's [ __ ]
ass made millions of dollars on crypto
so i refuse to come he doesn't want to
come back and we we we listen to the
comments and the comments were like you
guys are nothing without steve and then
we're like well maybe we are yeah
nothing without steve
[Laughter]
you're right you're right
so we gotta [ __ ] do all of this burn
all of the money left in our account to
get the best suite at the trump tower
thank you but you said you know what
we're going to troll trump
and then we're going to get biden hats
in here okay yeah because we need to
equalize everything tom's on the golf
course right now he's feeling it dude
yeah he's feeling that [ __ ] he's like oh
i can't believe a bite and had his
inside of my [ __ ] towel jake just got
me
[Laughter]
we got him dude we got another sick bird
big time but a part of me felt a little
bad because i don't want to troll that
hard so i said let's let's let's make
this eve even that's good man it's crazy
the hats came with the room they came
with a suite when you buy a 200 yeah you
get you get a bite in hat and uh make
america great nothing beats making a
point with a really neutral stance it's
kind of funny because even though we're
making it even for some reason i feel
like the red ones weigh a little more
as far as when you wear it it stands out
more
does it make you feel more racist it
doesn't feel even it makes it feel more
powerful though the red one it's a very
vibrant red though yeah this is very
neutral i want to start beating up
immigrants
like asian senior citizens no no no
that's another one yeah yeah that's
that's that's a difference that's kind
of this that doesn't even require a hat
yeah i want to start talking about how i
want to help all the immigrants but
really i'm just trying to use it to [ __ ]
a chick at the bar
[Laughter]
i don't really do anything except for
going to a voter booth
so yeah
that's where i'm at
uh it's gonna work too i think so well
what's new with all of you guys i
haven't seen you guys during the the
whole break i quit jk it was [ __ ]
epic uh like one month off
[ __ ] what's up okay okay so your life
is better without jk it was so great
how's your life been thank you for
quitting during our vacation
because then we didn't have to shoot
it's a coincidence yeah i mean we did
you for a couple of days when you were
moving to vegas i didn't know yeah that
it was going to be vacation i thought i
was making a bold stance and quitting
um but yeah so you haven't even thought
about us since you quit
uh no no no i mean bart lives here i
hadn't seen you the whole time oh yeah
it was just it was a busy month anyway
because we everyone's doing christmas
[ __ ] and also
new year's [ __ ] but um
no it was fun it was it was it's funny
how i quit
um
you know while i was moving and i mean
it kind of fell
together perfectly because when you quit
we had that last week yeah of you
without uh you know yeah and and a lot
of people believed uh or they no they
didn't believe they predicted because
they're so smart they knew that you're
completely quitting know i had quit yes
i kind of think they're right the fact
that anyone [ __ ] believes anything i
say anymore actually blows my mind well
it's you you sell it very well though
well thank you you have a very straight
face it actually it blows my mind i've
heard i had a gay face
it blows my mind that people believe
anything that anyone posts yeah you know
i mean like everyone curates their ig
right so when people like say stuff like
even when they're like oh my god oh oh
oh like like you know they'll be like oh
bart and julia relationship goals i'm
like how the [ __ ] do you know we could
be fighting every [ __ ] damn i hate
her ass we might be on the board uh
verge of the divorce oh that's true we
know we know a lot of relationships that
look perfect i'm like don't don't
[ __ ] believe what i say unless i'm
selling something that it's 100 true yep
other than that don't [ __ ] believe
anything that i said although all the
[ __ ] weights in this gym are hella
fake yeah fake ass we were there we went
to go check out the little plastic ones
that float on water all of bart's
political beliefs fake as [ __ ] dude bart
has bubble gums dude he doesn't have
real guns what's a bubble guy it's all
synthetic
bro
[Laughter]
you guys are much more creative than i
am yeah that was good i thought it was
bubbles coming out of my guts dude
that's honestly i don't know so how do
you like the vegas life steve oh man
it's you know what's crazy uh
i i've been pushing to come to vegas for
a long time right like that's 2017. in
2017 i was like well because it's part
of my my plan with crypto cash out i was
like dude i gotta cash out in vegas
stays on taxes and [ __ ] but then
like actually living here like being
here i i obviously came here a bunch of
times and like stayed in like where
where we actually live like a couple
times not not going to strip just having
my own vegas experience off strip
i know there's a lot of vegas haters out
there but dude this place is like i feel
like i found like a secret hidden gem
that people don't know about especially
where we live like it's beautiful i feel
like it's like the altcoin that's gonna
go to the moon that no one knows about
yeah and i don't even know why people
hate on it do people hate on it well
here like what's something someone says
it's usually people who live here but
they but they live somewhere that i
don't that sucks i think so like you
know i mean or at least that i've seen
like i don't know that i'll hit you i'll
hit you with the objections this is what
people usually say but your guys's vegas
experience is because you guys are
millionaires
and it's so sweet to be a millionaire
anywhere in the world
that's true that's what i'm saying yeah
that's what i mean you're right because
you could be like making a quarter mill
a year in la and you live in poverty
versus if you live in [ __ ] oklahoma
or some [ __ ] dude i was just telling
this to anthony last night because
you've been staying with me right i was
like i was like you know what for the
first time i can actually see where my
money is like like when you when i lived
in la i don't see my money when i walk
when i get out of my car and go into my
apartment or like you mean like your
taxes and all that where's my property
tax score why is there a hole in the
floor right yeah exactly what why is my
place this way if i'm spending this much
on it because we spent a [ __ ] ton of
money on our on our condo and i'm like
you know it's fine it's for la it was
like a nice size and [ __ ] but dude for
here i can look around see exactly where
my money is there's no money
everything's clean everything's big yeah
i got a pool it's like it's just crazy
dude it's honestly great but what about
the haters that say they go there's
nothing to do here what are we going to
do gamble
bro the strip is 15 minutes away
what if they say i hate take a
helicopter go see a [ __ ] grand canyon
in 15 minutes you can sit back that's
millionaire [ __ ] though bro
[ __ ] steve that's the 100 [ __ ] everyone
does it steve literally has a helicopter
pad next to his pool he just hasn't
painted the h on it yet yep all right so
one of you like are you know modest like
30 000 a year kind of guy yeah what's
your deal it goes even further here dude
it probably is even better
honestly
that's true if you if you make like
middle class money
or if you make lower income money vegas
is still better because the prices of
food gas
like everyday items is cheaper groceries
i remember going to the grocery store
i'm like
we have hella farms in california right
it's closer why the [ __ ] are the
groceries more expensive in california
when it takes longer to deliver to vegas
you can't be bringing that logic into
this conversation okay fine i'll tell
you i thought we were keeping it
emotional but it's dry dry as [ __ ] i
hate that [ __ ] that's why i live in
hawaii top 10 reasons why somebody
should live in vegas i have to say that
took me about a month like my hands
cracked like the first oh it cracked
yeah like my uh my knuckles like because
your hands are already wet in a dry
weather yeah yeah yeah for sure that's
why you're human i thought you got that
from like moving or something like well
i did i i cut my knuckle while i was
moving but it split over here like
because of dryness yeah isn't that isn't
that like nikki has a bruise right here
no because that's because i heard so she
she cracked that's this that's what this
steel chair
because she fell down the stairs on one
part of her head
[Laughter]
the top 10 reasons why yeah top 10
reasons why you should live in the oh
there's so many there's so many good
restaurants here that obesity is oh
that's
there's too many good restaurants and
everything and it entices me to be fat
right okay
that's vegas exclusive by the way
there's too many beautiful women and it
entices me to be cheating all day okay
and not only
it's only a drive away to get legal
brothel hood that's true so then i could
be a bad boy legally brotherhood at all
costs weight is legal here we do horn in
city limits or it has to be outside
outside of vegas
county cloud county is the the thing i'm
a bobber wait outside in
clark county yeah and then so if you
just go right outside clark county it's
a county law yeah then you could you
could step over the line and do whatever
the hell you want over there there's a
city called
that's a couple hours away that has the
bunny ranch and the chicken ranch and
they have what's the chicken ranch a
brothel i was at the vadara recently
yeah and me and nicky were staying there
this is what we were while we were
moving um or while we were in the
process of signing for our house which
is you know the best part about signing
from my house is i had never seen it
until the day that we got i still
gangster which is what the realtor guy
said he was like in all my years i've
been doing this for 30 years i've never
had somebody sign for their primary
residence having seen it the day of you
just trust nikki's vision i trusted
nikki but more so um you trust vegas i i
have wanted to come to vegas since 2017
right
when when
all this was going down there's just so
much going on in crypto i didn't want to
step away and miss anything because like
there was just so much going on so so
because honestly and nick you know this
actually anthony and you know this joe
if you step away and you miss say an
airdrop or something like that you could
miss thousands of dollars
so it was during one of those times
where i was like dude i could i don't
want to get chopped up on this so [ __ ]
it you go ahead show me video all that
stuff and then we had our friend ray
come out and he i trust him too so
i'm not i wasn't worried about it but
the day i saw it i was like
damn i can't even believe i'm gonna get
this house so it was that easy and it's
cheaper than your la house cheaper than
l.a and it's bigger by like five times
it's so much bigger and it's in a gated
community yep it's tight and a
helicopter pad and a free trash can and
a free yeah that's a park trash can it
was a park steve has a park commercial
grade commercial why does it have a
screw lid on top you can't take the lid
off you can't how do you change the bag
or i don't know who brought it in there
i think it's just for garden clippings
and [ __ ]
well how do you get the trash out i
don't know i think a park ranger comes
and empties it yeah
a bear it's part of your hoa dude the
guy comes and he [ __ ] clears it up
you gotta flip it upside down and screw
it from the bottom he's gonna vacuum it
out all right reason three why vegas
sucks too many casinos i could lose all
my money
i'd be saving a lot of money but i also
spend a lot of money too much prime rib
everybody technically i think you're on
four but it's all good four
oh i did the hot girls in the brothel
yeah
the other one is the air quality is
better so you live longer and then which
means that you don't cherish life as
much i heard it's hot for for two months
you've been here through the summer yeah
that's probably gonna be the worst part
uh yeah there's a week that's like 1 15.
pretty bad it's pretty crazy but i lived
in the valley that's why i was used to
that we we had that same [ __ ] so i was
already there yeah that's what that's
like whatever
if anything the weather
reminds me of my childhood because i
grew up on the east coast and like the
east coast in virginia i like living in
hawaii better though
you look like a virginia versus virginia
that's the
do or die hawaii versus virginia oh
vegas yeah i also sound like they they
really make vegas sound like it sucks
these all sound like i feel like if you
grew up anywhere you can make your area
sound like it sucks yeah true
what do native vegas people say as far
as why they don't like it [ __ ] tourists
they just spent too much time here i
hate san diego because i grew up there
well our barbell photographer
is from vegas
and he's been trying to tell me as if
like steve would tell us about the next
big coin he was like honestly i don't
know why people don't move here that
much i'm like for reals why is he
whisper like it's a secret it's like
cause it really doesn't want people to
come here and drive up prices right
honestly i love whispering anytime you
whisper it sounds so much fun you would
like tell me you would tell me things
and i'm like yeah yeah yeah i vape this
works i'm like ellie till i die right
i'm like nothing's better than [ __ ]
l.a until i started coming here more and
more and more and more i'm like dude i
think what he's saying is kind of true
well you're also like this is my forever
home now yeah and then you're like no
this is my forever home
forever home only means a year yeah it's
only every year that's my definition i
don't know anyone that's owned as many
brand new homes as bart has brand new
brand new builds how many people have
brand new homes three homes in a row but
it's not brand new if it's a year old so
he's got to move into a new village yeah
he got old after the year he's like dude
he's like this is old as [ __ ] how do you
find brand new homes in california
yeah you don't you go to riverside you
gotta build it yourself dude
not in l.a no yeah damn ellie's a
wastelander but you know i'm sure i'm
sure it's i'm very new to vegas
obviously right but i've been coming
here i mean me and nicky this is our
number one place that we came to like
year for years like we came here like
three times a year oh so it's like an
easy transition easy transition yeah
it's just but and it's it's just it's
just beautiful man i'm really excited
about it and maybe maybe that will wayne
who knows but um i i uh like i have
romantic feelings towards virginia
because i got ripped out of there when i
was a kid you loved it there i loved it
there but then i had to move to san
diego and i hated it there i felt like i
was like in prison when i moved there
yeah because i got taken away from all
my because in virginia you can tell
people you're not from around here are
you but then in san diego they probably
are they are yeah yeah exactly what's
what's your biggest pet peeve about san
diego like what do you think i just
spent too much time there i was there
pick some though pixel escondido you
ever been there dude
yeah trying to get to san diego it's
like a [ __ ] ant hill is it close to
the beach what does that mean no it's
like it's like 45 minutes are there ants
san diego probably has the best weather
in all of the west coast it has great
weather i i think san diego is like if
you just want to chill and not worry
about nothing
as far as
surprising weather conditions if san
diego is the place to be yeah that's a
retirement area it is retirement where
you go to dive you got a sleepy energy
to it i don't enjoy it
here's something that sucks about vegas
if you're a graffiti artist there's
nothing you can really do here you can't
battle anybody because it's all blank
everyone just respects it a little bit
everyone just respects just covered up
right away too they do a really good job
of that if there is any graffiti let's
just like cover up graffiti games
well who does the best cover just flat
paint
eggshell white look how well this
matches
what do you guys feel is like the best
local thing to do in vegas then because
i know
vegas from a very touristy i visit this
[ __ ] type of spot but like when
it comes to like living here you know
you guys mentioned you guys have not you
barely even go to the strip right my
favorite thing is done the nature
so there's the dancer what do you mean
no like red rock so that's a national
forest or a national park he's a forest
it's uh it's uh no there's actually a
forest in there really yeah so if you go
to red rock it's like 10 minutes away um
and then there's lee canyon where you
went snowboarding there's a ton of trees
there
um it's like a big off-roading outdoors
like adventure town okay so i would call
that a negative
what's your positive there's one oh no
going to red rock going to i mean
checking out all these different i mean
even just go in there to like they have
a [ __ ] imax movie theater in there
and [ __ ] so he's talking about red rock
casino he's talking about red rock the
rock
i want to go to the rock i've seen the
rock it looks beautiful and stuff but
i'm chill and then i turn left into the
casino thing
yeah but the nature is dope because you
could go on hikes and there's no
graffiti or whatever
versus like eaten canyon you can go on
hikes and there's no dude go to eden
canyon they're like why is there [ __ ]
griffin bro don't talk [ __ ] don't talk
[ __ ] about my [ __ ] hiking trail yo
dude i've been glad since i was five bro
it's my idea it's a great contrast of
like art on the wall which is graffiti
and then [ __ ] i enjoy eaton canyon
yeah all right [ __ ] [ __ ] well if
you like it then you like it then don't
go to my red rock is that some very
family man [ __ ] though you know what i
mean i see how cute that [ __ ] is you
know what you're a curated instagram you
and your [ __ ] family all nice and
well i've been doing like nature and
like that kind of stuff it's just cool
i'm able to bring the family along with
it yeah but i seen the behind the scenes
it's all fake dude he just throws
[ __ ] tiger hey [ __ ] be cute and
[ __ ] chill shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] pose
like a mom and [ __ ]
and then he's like joe take this [ __ ]
picture we're a happy family and i'm
like okay
he's getting abused too and he's like
what are you doing watching tomahawk
spider-man you're spider-man toby
maguire your spider-man is toby [ __ ]
mcguire and then it's like i love my
family
on instagram i love them
you promised you'd tell me a new type of
story what's the most interesting i've
been waiting for this you said you were
going to tell me i'm good they're kind
of boring
that's it
yeah let me see what's the next he's
trying to keep steve around dude i don't
know the last milestone steve starts
falling asleep as he does well he has to
be like what impresses me and we're out
of time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you